[Music]
I'm sure a lot of people have photos on
Facebook and Twitter that they don't
want their employers to see well I'm
very excited about this now there's a
service called social sweeper that can
scan those sites for damaging or
embarrassing images and then delete them
for you which is a really great idea and
everyone's talking about it but it's
already has competition from another
business that claims to provide a
similar service for a fraction of the
cost and guess what they're actually our
newest sponsor take a look hello people
in photographs are you a person or
persons who is seeking the new job but
is worried that your employer will
discover photographs of you online that
are gross or nasty or skanky or perience
then you're probably thinking the only
solution is to burn down the internet
don't even try it it don't work well now
there's a better way which mickey and
sneaky damaging photo dee damages
picture this they've got a big job
interview and everything's doing
gangbusters until this happens that was
a perfect interview I hereby offer you
the job
oh wait look I'll never be president of
Apple Computer
millions period by letting us Mickey and
Snooki doctor your photos until they're
squeaky-clean
it's easy the photo of you time went on
with your buddies boom
now you're jammin with Aerosmith what
can a doobie zing now you're playing an
ocarina the South American woodwind
instrument bottoming out on the bathroom
floor now you're a real Top Gun
community college nice chicken through
the Oval Office you must be important
maybe you were doing some gross sex
stuff or did you just win a Latin Grammy
Award maybe the gang bang
congratulations you just cleaned up at
the Latin Grammys and all this happens
in our state of the art graphic design
facility just look we know what you're
thinking how can two disbarred attorneys
you specialize in a divorce possibly be
trusted with your compromising
photographs don't worry about it even
the dirty ones the frame is small
between the Orange Julius and the
Cinnabon if you see the fordist books
we've walked you far
I don't know
you